i'm steve mold and i think we should
stop using pi and start using tau and I
met Parker and I think Steve said
something ridiculous
I think pi is fantastic it's wonderful
and even if this we know what was an
equal race where we've been using both
the more even if tau had been
established first I'm still pretty
propyne Wow that's my fan base big well
let's talk about this so pi is the
circle constant it's the constant that
defines a circle and the argument is
great so far
let's think of a reasonable definition
of what circle is there what are the
classic is are all points equidistant
from a single point that distance is the
radius and if you're ever doing maths
using circles you talk about the radius
all your all your equations about
circles talk about the radius unless
you're an engineer you use diameter but
as a mathematician you use the radius
the circle constant should surely be
defined in terms of the radius but it
isn't pi is the this conference divided
by the diameter which is crazy so the
circle constant should be the
circumference divided by the radius when
you do that you get 2 times pi and so
we're not saying let's redefine pinecone
call it 6.28
but instead we're saying instead of
senator instead we're saying that's
going to be confusing so let's invent a
new constant will quite town to be
honest one of the points was quite nice
which is that if you're an engineer you
use pi and in fact historically we've
used pi because when you measure a
circle the only direct measurement you
can make is of the diameter and so
that's why historically we've done that
and to this day in precision engineering
we do that and yes you can do some very
nice maths with the radius you know in
circle but the only thing you can
directly measure is the diameter so
that's why we've used pie people say oh
but you know we have to put two pi into
lots of equations and then level a is
always 2 pi why don't we just use town
set there are as many fantastic
equations out there which use just the
single PI and there's no reason to bring
in two x so I see Steve is holding the
pen but I
my own so everyone's classic is the e to
the I PI job where e to the I PI plus
one equals zero and that that is using a
solitary PI out the front there and if
you want to go wild things like the area
of a torus this is a nice one
that equals PI square outside the major
radius squared finest the minor radius
squared so I'm still doing things in
terms of the radiuses but already I or
whatever but the PI squared that's
lovely what you want you want for I mean
how you are now squared on for what the
absolute ass got on for and I explain
why and this is important me okay let's
just say that matters topics a couple of
nice equations there two things I'd say
let's look at for example the area of a
circle so we're looking at the area PI R
squared lovely look yes okay doing
visible but here's the problem here's
the problem if we reframe that in town
that would be tau by 2 R squared you
think okay that's less beautiful but
this tells us something important this
tells us something this is information
that you're obscuring by using point
because you can do right by simplifying
you know listen you can derive the area
of a circle by integrating so you say
okay here's that full circle let's look
at the area of this little strip where
the the width of it is you know Delta R
and this is are going up and so this is
this is for R whatever so you integrate
the area of this is pi r dr now no but
tell me actually touch it
so pi is easy to use and so and then you
end up with you know a half tau r
squared and so that half tells you
something tells you you've done an
integration to get there but in a
question lights obscures it similarly
with this you know that if you had tax
credit before that would tell you
something this equation here let's do
reframe them e to the I tau minus one
equals zero and the great thing is that
is a full circle right if you want to go
through half a circle then it's e to the
I tau over 2 if you want to go quarter
of a circle it's e to the I tau by 4 the
pie is confusing it's especially
confusing for children when they're
learning as well it's say okay a full
circle is 2 pi ok so that half a circle
is PI a quarter of a circle is PI by 2
so this is always this fact I'm to that
you've got to keep in your mind when
you're when you're doing calculations
and actually if you're if you're a
seasoned mathematician you'll probably
always thinking in terms of 2 pi anyway
and so let's just stop thinking in terms
of this new biography of your you want
halves here you don't want halves over
there and also no one halves here
because the half tells you this works
out just as nicely because if you want
to integrate and you've got your 2 pi r
dr then you get a wonderful thing you
can simplify because you end up with
this yet that's where it's really wet up
with that so in this particular case i
and the half it simplifies it yeah
that's just there's nowhere else in
maths where you say you know what let's
not simplify it let's leave it in a more
complicated form because it you know but
in fact we this is the one case where
you think actually it's useful to have a
2 there because we can cancel 8 it most
other cases you don't get to do that
cancel because you're not because you're
not dividing by 2 later on in most cases
you end up with an equation that's got 2
pi Oh smart people who I know you
respect and I know you respect the guy
sitting next year maybe the guys anyway
yeah a lot of smart people make the case
for tau yeah how do you explain their
reasoning like how do you I mean you
don't think staves an idiot but he he
has this feeling about Tao that you
disagree with wise what's different
about his thinking to yours yeah a lot
of people do have very good arguments
for Tao I don't do that very good
arguments for PI and
that there is a wonderful thing where I
think people like the fact that it's
different and that they're going ooo
everyone else has got it wrong we can
change this into how is better and oh
you know ah people trying to know people
trying to do mass they think PI's all
that no they're wrong but I just I don't
I don't think it there's any great
advantage other than it people it can be
a bit more exclusive to sale where all
of a towel when I think PI works just as
well in all cases it's got I no history
no historical you know the fact that's
God bit of heritage doesn't mean we
should keep it around necessarily but
it's worked for a very long time it's
there for very good reasons I don't
nothing people have thrown at me in
terms of towel saying it's better
it isn't anyway you gain as much as you
lose from switching from both of them
have their disadvantages and advantages
I don't think there's enough for entire
overhaul of the subject because people
think of what this particular equation
looks a bit nicer all but we've lost the
fact that you get you know negative
numbers in Euler's identity and even
even your arguments with circles and
this is my clincher this is what I
genuinely think pi is nicer with if you
got tau right if you do towel radians
right you do an entire revolution you
end up right back where you started
tau gets you nowhere right PI with PI if
you do pi radians you actually get
somewhere and I think if you want to
unit to measure things the unit
shouldn't be the whole thing all right
au nut should be a section of it and so
it's more nuanced and for that reason I
think is divine I like that / you know
360 may just gone too far no one would
use that kind of a unit Steve yeah I've
heard your talk I thought you took a
little bit and you seem to have an
enjoyment of the history of mathematics
math C is beautiful and pure but it's
also got great stories yeah are you
willing to ditch PI which is one of our
most important cling to loved story
don't overstate my case you one word
progress
yeah I think okay the historical point
is is a good one
you know historically we used to
sacrifice goats
and I think we should keep doing that
and now I think I mean you can't just
clink something because of history
having said that having said that one
argument against how is that you know pi
is very well established and we'll just
never replace it the strong argument for
me is that it's tau is is more intuitive
and so from an educational point of view
I think in terms of understanding
circles I'm working with so cause it's
hammering let's just call it a circle
okay
it's just say you think you trying to
teach kids angles and you go what angle
is this all of it sostay that's just
that's just that's not under system this
is all the way round you start doing the
bigger the circle of course though if I
made you Education Minister of the world
yeah all right yeah what would you do
about this situation well it here's the
thing I think you can actually slowly
bring it in because um because when it's
whenever you can use PI and tau at the
same time because wherever you see two
pi you can write down so you don't have
to change any techno doctor suddenly
over all textbooks and redefine PI you
can you can bring it in slowly and so if
I was educationalist of the world and I
hope to be one day you can you can bring
it in very slowly but your argument
seems to be that the Tau people aren't
wrong it's just a bit needless it's
extra work they're insufficiently right
yeah so what's wrong with Education
Minister for the world there next to you
slowly bringing in tower oh you mean you
I have no I have no problem with towel
sitting alongside pie no problem with I
think it's very important you're right
to teach radians in terms of it's a
whole circle and we're splitting it up
into smaller amounts and how it links to
wonderful things like this but I you
never see anyone who's plugging tau
going you know what this would be useful
as well they're always like PI is wrong
and that with highs not wrong ties no
it's perfectly serviceable it's worked a
treat and it's a wonderful concert and
and I think genuinely it's got a lot
more going for it for doing maths then
tell but there's many things where you
could say historically like why don't we
count in base 12 that would be nicer but
we don't even base 10 which admit what I
will almost say base 2
offers more advantages if we switch to
that then if we switch to towel so why
are we getting so emotional about our
rationals when we could be a bit more
rational about our based systems so I'm
stopping the tape before you go start
okay four point eight kilograms so we do
varying angles there would be a clock of
order legal that way rather than that
way quite why we do that I have no idea
it's kind of a similarly if I went up so
to the size of a boulder so that this
was